euromaxx highlights and here's your host
laila ha rock hello and a very warm
welcome to our highlights show let's see
what we have lined up for you this time
round surprising italian designer for
what you love yannis furniture creations
creative profiling a top mobile games
manufacturer and fearless Austria's Tony
bender puts parachutes to the test
well when getting a pet for the family
most people will pick something
traditional like a dog or a cat and then
there are those that love bugs they may
not bring you your newspaper fetch your
slippers or wag their tail as you
scratch their head but as any bug loving
kid will tell you if you like to watch
your pets nothing beats an army of
marching ants this is camponotus Hokulea
knows the site of the black carpenter
ant must be terrifying to other ant
species the carpenter ant can be up to
1.6 centimeters long making it europe's
biggest species it likes to live in
rotting wood it eats flies and
mosquitoes and if you bother it it will
bite you and dealer Martin sebesta
things ants make cute pets espacio no
info bomber is what's fascinating about
ants is their social life there is
constant communication among them they
create something together they expand
the nest or bring in food or share the
food they have different occupations and
it's always fascinating to watch them
mozzie fustian sebesta a trained
industrial mechanic has been fascinated
by hands since he was a teenager in 2003
he opened up his own and chopped in
Berlin the first in Germany it is more
than 20 species they come from all over
the world sebesta has between ten and
twenty thousand colonies in stock that
includes some exotic species like the
South American leaf cutter ant which can
carry 30 times its own body weight the
leaves feet up fungus which in turn
becomes the ants dinner just booze on
the bottom touch the leaf cutter ants
nests can be so huge in nature they can
be as large as 50 square meters and
eight meters deeply nested photo/peter
grew soft sometimes private owners can
no longer handle the colony after two
years why should we get them in touch
with the zoo that needs to be considered
that's a stressful enough info box
testing Zoltan Bianca svenska also has a
fondness for exotic ants
biology teacher has 16 different species
in her Berlin apartment for example the
South American patch I condola apcalis
an aggressive predator that stings like
a wasp could this be the ideal house pet
skip kushina goner there are a number of
reasons why I think it's a good pet I
can create a beautiful landscape I can't
do that with a dog or a cat average kind
of lunch after hold I'm fascinated by
this mini ecosystem equals this team
finishing deshpande detailer cost me at
sneak it isn't expensive to feed ants
just a few grasshoppers and sugar water
and they're not loud loud so they are a
comparatively inexpensive pet though a
queen from this Australian species costs
160 euros and there is another
disadvantage to keeping ants the exotic
species cannot legally be allowed into
the domestic ecosystem unset Sigma
swallow ma sista first you should ask
are these ants under some form of legal
protection is the species endangered you
shouldn't try to maintain a colony if
the species is endangered and non
competitions and then are there any
permits required Australia is very
strict about what you can bring into or
out of the country I whole skit so a
beginner shouldn't start with an exotic
species but a domestic one like these
ants Martin sebesta produces and sells
starter sets from 50 euros up
Sylvester delivers the ants with two
terrariums and all the necessary
equipment one Queen and one worker ant
are enough to produce a colony of
thousands let's and ultimately we see
ants outdoors but we don't see what they
do inside their nest we just seen and
dragging something into it but then what
happens if I open or destroy an ant nest
all I see is a swarming throng vestido
Martin and that's why Martin's avesta
regards the ant as the best house pet
his shop now has 10 employees they take
orders and send ants all over Europe
well next week the world's largest
international furniture fair opens in
Milan Italy exhibitors are currently
adding the finishing touches to their
designs so we had it to Milan and caught
up with ferruccio love Yanni we has made
quite a name for himself in the industry
over the past 25 years his unique range
of furniture combines the old with the
new furniture with an element of
surprise
this dresser by ferruccio la vie ani is
called whole the Italian designer uses
many of his designs to scrutinize the
classic principles of style like clear
lines symmetry or purity inform capable
de volta d I try to give up my objects a
special aesthetic or artistic note
equalled with this design I feel a
little bit like the rebellious son from
a good family who brings his grandma's
heirlooms into a squatters house he
lives with them in a totally different
way even you not throw maldo Farrugia la
vie on ease newest project good
vibrations is still just a draft on his
computer the inspiration for deformed
furniture came to him through video
interference a little pieces like a
solid waste autopilot but I got the idea
to have a piece of furniture in the
house that looks as if it's distorted
this will think the vibration that
really hits you when you pass by what
they pass occurs even ask all safe but
first the designer had to convince his
client of the idea when they signed
their mouths were gaping open like this
since then la vie ami has been working
full force the first distorted wardrobe
has to be finished in time for the Milan
Furniture Fair which opens next week
this wooden table is called Toya or
tablecloth la vianney likes to play with
the appearance of objects and the
contrast between individual elements
like in this sideboard called evolution
laughter leone an indelible irony is
important in my work this table for
example is called bidding yow that's a
dialect word for joke but I don't want
to be funny at all costs irony always
has to suit the product so I'm more
reserved la vianney works for famous
manufacturers for foscarini he designed
these lamps called orbital
and supernovae
pero cheer la vianney has been art
director for the cartel company for 23
years his land 4g from 2003 is a best
seller ferruccio has also worked for
Dolce & Gabbana designing for boutiques
restaurants and bars he knows both
designers from his college days maybe
Jane let me gladly he's one day they
tell me we've noticed that we have a lot
of things from you and what may be
easier if you just designed them
straight for us without us first having
to look for your products upon parabola
Java la vianney has his work cut out in
the final days before the Milan
furniture fair he rushes from one client
to the next on top of that his distorted
furniture collection has made the
headlines journalists are standing in
line to interview him but he doesn't
want to be branded because of his style
no magic wand Lumia Phoebe annuity I
just don't like it when people put
labels on me like neo-baroque or the guy
with the distorted furniture I want to
be perceived as an all-around designer
this is his collage sofa from 2012 its a
mix of style and epochs that people can
put together themselves it sells for
about 10,000 heroes
well look KEO sempre of course I always
want people to find what I make
attractive but not because they see the
signature belongs to me that looks deal
because they like it okay cause if they
then say oh that's from la vianney
that's when I'm most happiest ever
granted this mosaic signboard is to be
finished before the Milan fair the
largest and most important trade fair of
its kind in the world it's just one of
many new designs by ferruccio la vianney
all after dust clouds disrupted
international flights back in 2011 the
world became acquainted with the mighty
volcanoes of Iceland the fact that it
has so many volcanoes also means that
the island is home to a number of
underground lava caves the recently
discovered bhuri cave was formed 5,000
years ago and it's located south of the
capital R I kvick with a guide who knows
what they're doing you can trek through
the ice-covered cave as long as you're
physically and mentally up for a
challenge
these caves are located 10 meters
underground spectacular icicles hang
from the walls a trip to the lava caves
is exciting but also risky and of course
you know you have those big huge rocks
covered with ice and it's really
slippery this group of hikers set out a
few hours earlier they've already walked
two kilometres across a lava plain
temperatures are just above freezing do
you guide Corey Bjorn subtle is taking
to Icelandic tourists into the brewery
cave which is around 5,000 years old
it's basically a tunnel with a few paths
that you could get lost but you should
always be able to find out if you maybe
if you didn't have a light you would get
lost we're going in without a kite is
not recommended it's fact you can get
lost and hurt and cost a lot of trouble
the only way into the cave is through a
hole that's barely 50 centimetres wide
this is no place for anyone who suffers
from claustrophobia a lot of tourists
panic
the boar ekav was discovered in may 2005
by bjorn roarsome Corey's father he's
one of iceland's best known cave
researchers and taught his son
everything he knows such as how the
caves were formed this cave was from
5,000 years ago in an eruption in a
volcano that was close by um but a cave
like this is formed the interruption of
course where the lava flows out of the
volcano and love are usually flows in
channels and if it moves quickly enough
and for a long period a roof starts
building a topic because it's called the
rat top then in this next to the lower
so our roof starts forming its minus 2
degrees Celsius in the cave and icicles
in all shapes and sizes jut out from the
walls
making your way through the cave
requires some climbing skill Corey and
the tourists take nearly an hour to
cover just the first 150 metres the
group's advance is slow and careful do
we have had some accident Ellen was a
girl that broke her neck last summer but
she made it he's fine today but yeah
there are accidents can happen the caves
extend for almost a kilometer the walls
of lava stone are up to 10 meters high
and 10 meters wide after about three and
a half hours the group reaches the end
of the trail and the edge of a
spectacular lava pit 17 meters deep one
of the deepest lava pits on earth
Wow I think it's amazing actually this
is my first time in na in a cave so I'm
really really it's really fascinating
actually oh definitely do it again sir
eight hours after they started the group
makes their way across a lava plain in
the darkness it's a one and a half hour
hike back to the car
oh it's so many people nowadays owning
smart phones mobile computer games are
on the rise hundreds of companies have
developed gaming apps in recent years
but only a handful catch on worldwide
one of the latest crazes is called royal
revolt and it's fast becoming a hit with
gamers of all ages he's one angry Prince
after returning home from boarding
school his errand waiting finds his
relatives have carved up the kingdom
between them the aim of royal revolt is
to help the young prince went back what
is rightfully his the game was developed
by flare games together with its
subsidiary keen flare just days after
hitting app stores the game was
downloaded by more than a million gamers
worldwide now it's on the shortlist for
a prize at this year's German Game
Awards ina million downloads hottie 1
million downloads sounds like an awful
lot but you shouldn't forget that there
are billions of smartphones out there
but bought it's a respectable figure and
many games never manage to get close to
that amount nevertheless we're aiming
for more a lot more class casting is no
stranger to success the 33 year old
founded his first computer game studio
10 years ago and turned it into one of
the world's biggest games publishers a
year and a half ago he set up flare
games in karlsruhe the company's team of
50 developers turns creative ideas into
popular mobile games young nephew LaVon
we've got a lot of veterans from the
gaming industry here some come from
classic pc games and from the online
games branch phenom ayodele some of them
have been around for more than 10 years
that's one deaf woman it's definitely
the sort of company that isn't very
common here in Germany off by via we
managed because we have many well-known
people from the gaming industry here and
are attracting talented young people who
can help support our team Zack what
understood some con
one veteran game designer is Ralph
Martian chick as royal revolts lead
artist it was his job to oversee the
artistic development of the game
together with Israeli animator enough
Terry the games lead character has been
kept simple what at first glance might
look like a game designed for children
is actually targeted towards grown up
gamers dispute skill is philotic uh no
formal yet the aim of the game is simple
you have to conquer one castle after
another in order to reclaim the kingdom
and especially gunson megaman couple
once you start you realize there's a lot
more to it than meets the eye watch
below they include you first but
generally is easy for players to get
into the game and play it does it has a
certain depth to it but you'll be
finished with your mission after three
to four minutes and can do other things
and then come back to the game later ivy
dolphin sales of mobile games doubled in
germany between 2011 and 2012 tiny wings
is one of the most popular the idea
behind it is simple but it's been a big
success keep it simple was a principal
followed by the developers of word
wonder it's also in the running for a
prize at this year's German Game Awards
the precursor to today's mobile games
can be seen here at Berlin's computer
game Museum this pocket soccer game from
Mattel was way ahead of its time when it
hits stores back in 1976 nokia released
snake more than 20 years later it was
the first game that could be played on a
cell phone yo bien cielo hum mobile
games got an incredible boost thanks to
smartphones they were first intended to
just make calls but now they are so
powerful that they are perfectly suited
to playing games on and could be
permanently hooked up to the web awesome
stand up mrs. 19 zintan that enables
multiplayer gaming anytime and anywhere
this
be made possible by the advent of the
smartphone and has led to the expansion
of the whole mobile game sector ice
mobians finger food the programmers at
Flair games love to play games whether
they're board games or up the mobile
variety at the moment they're working on
six new mobile games two of them are
slated to hit app stores in May the
developers are keeping them closely
under wraps but have already disclosed
that they'll be strategy games here in
Germany people love their bread and the
best and most popular thing are spread
on it is of course butter if you didn't
already know butter is made entirely
from cream but its taste changes
according to the production methods one
of the best homemade butters is set to
come from a farm near Sweden's
second-largest city gotten berg the
butter is so popular it's now being sold
to many of Europe's top restaurants top
chefs from all over Europe rave about
this butter and gladly serve it in their
gourmet restaurants
and this is where it comes from about
half an hour's drive north of gothenburg
in sweden Xanterra bring and patrick yo
Han Xiang spent around a year
experimenting with different butter
recipes and production methods they
first asked a top chef to try their
butter four years ago he loved it and
immediately ordered 40 kilograms to know
it's separated into butter and
buttermilk my grandmother she was a
butter maker in the 40s 50s and 60s and
she taught me to wash away all traces of
this buttermilk this white hair because
then the butter will keep longer but we
do not do as my grandmother taught me we
keep the buttermilk inside that way we
have lots more flavor homemade sour
cream is the second reason for the
butters special taste the couple leave
the sour cream to ferment for three days
with special bacterial cultures it's
then whipped in a machine which
separates the butter and the buttermilk
about 200 kilograms are produced each
week and sent to 20 or so top
restaurants across Europe kilo costs
around 18 euros the industrial butter is
made in a modern machine it takes the
whole process takes a couple of seconds
head chef Stefan Kyle Sean orders around
four kilos of the butter every week for
the national star form restaurant in
Gothenburg Karl Sean serves the butter
with bread he says it's much too good
for cooking
that he don't cannon yeah nantou beer
hmm this handmade butter it's it had the
right sourness it has a right saltness
and you can find a little bit of the
buttermilk still in the butter and it
gives a lot of flavor for the butter so
it's for me it's the most perfect butter
to use tweeting on bread
great food starts with top ingredients
and one of those is most definitely the
butter made by Sandra bring and Patrick
Johan shop
next up we'll meet a man with a serious
adrenaline addiction and if you're into
paragliding you'll be very happy to know
that Tony bender does what he does the
Bavarian native tests parachutes for
paragliding that means it's his job to
really put a parachute to the test
needless to say he's one of the best in
the world which is a reassuring feeling
for anyone with gear that bears his seal
of approval this is innsbrook in the
Austrian Alps bad weather is expected
but for bender bad weather is sometimes
good he often tests paragliders under
extreme conditions today a cold front
with westerly winds and thunderstorms is
on the way mistakes could have fatal
consequences
disk finish the dangerous part about
paragliding is when you're just above
the ground so I always pay special
attention to the first 30 or 40 seconds
to make sure nothing is wrong then and
then as soon as I'm fifty to a hundred
meters above ground I can use my safety
valve condition do you rate then we're
not soon Tony's reserve parachutes are
his safety valve they're stowed in a
harness on his back and could be
essential in an emergency vendors
paraglider is a prototype whose
dimensions are two and a half by 11
meters of nylon
Bender's employer is a paraglider maker
near innsbrook here he discusses his
test flights with the developers this
paraglider will cost about 3,000 euros
if it passes all the tests it's marketed
to experienced flyers but Tony bender
doesn't just rise he also falls in his
test flights he has to put himself into
situations that are every pilots worst
nightmare like a collapsing canopy and a
deep lunch one of his greatest
achievements was crossing the Alps
without an engine in all as he rose and
defended over the mountain range he had
to negotiate forty thousand meters of
altitude what his passion involves risks
he's broken various bones at various
times when you didn't frequent when I'm
up there hanging under a paraglider and
don't know what it's going to do I feel
pretty uneasy and frightened but when
I'm testing one and trying all the
maneuvers and no it's okay and that it
can be controlled I feel safe I'm fine
well done lab you can see his before
Tony bender says he wants to paraglide
for many years to come because he only
really feels at home in the sky
and that wraps up our highlights show
thanks for being with us and we hope to
see you again very soon bye-bye